how do you decide what to do when you
pick one two three no waste you pick one
Mojave no ace is the right one you don't
[Music]
how do you deal with the unknown like
win it by recognizing I have no choice I
think it comes down to perfection and
like trying to make the right perfect
Hall and I think that the right perfect
call nine to ten times is the fastest
call so I tend not to overthink at all
I'm very intuitive and most of my
business mistakes have been to act too
quickly and then have to bail out I I've
found that speed trumps everything too
many people are crippled by the right
hire by the right meeting I say work
harder work more efficient make more
fifteen and thirty minute meetings that
leave you more time to do more things
and create more opportunities and don't
be crippled by choosing the right
opportunities or not
[Music]
I believe one of the most fascinating
excuses in life is that I'm so good at
so many things that I don't know which
one to pick so many of you are not
taking action because you overthink it
you overthink it you overthink it I
think the thing that bothers me is that
people are crippled by their options and
then actually aren't doing anything in
parallel they're lallygagging while they
decide if you're so good at so many
things you'll pick one you'll be good at
that and you can do a bunch of things
I'm doing a bunch of things you need to
be doing right need to be executing so
if there's three to four tangible things
going on in your mind you need to make
sure your internships your free time you
know whatever you can do to let you
taste them and get context around them
is what really matters I always say
deploy your resources that you can
afford to lose a lot of you don't have
the dollars I used to not have the
dollars but I had my time taking action
is especially if it doesn't cost you top
money and it's just time is always a
better answer than pondering or thinking
or trying to decide if this is gonna
work you don't know and one of the
smartest things I do as an entrepreneur
or a business person is I do things so I
can understand whether they work or not
[Music]
there was never a day in my life where I
didn't have something that I called the
80% of what I do what I think you need
to figure out is you've got to create at
least one burger I've got four right you
need to have one you can go and have
side dishes and if your meat if your
steak is perfect you'll always be able
to absorb the losses because they're
smaller losses I think a lot of people
just eat the potato or to pick already
onion order like I have the burger Wine
Library vaynermedia my personal brand
investing those are my burgers because
what the burger does is allows you to
create the wealth creation or the
financial stability that allows you to
go flirt and then when something over
here becomes bigger you can turn that
into the main part and that can become
the state too many people have all side
dishes and no steak I get everything
wrong it's just that I can't recall it
because once it's wrong I'm moving on to
the next thing I passed on uber twice
when they were raising money at a four
million dollar valuation I passed
even though Travis is one of my boys and
I think is one of the best entrepreneurs
in the world had I wrote a $25,000 check
into that company like I did any other
companies may be worth three hundred
million dollars Jesus is great you have
to understand this is my homie he's
acknowledged in my book that's what you
have to do when you're playing the game
that's what you have to understand when
you're not tripping or those misses are
gonna come in my career I look at losing
as a positive mainly because everybody
here doesn't like losing cuz they're
worried what other people think about
their loss I don't care what you think
about my losses my L is my L you're more
than welcome to leave a comment and
clown on me when I fail on something
when something doesn't work out I have
good news for you I don't give up what
you have to say I swear on my kids
health I'm obsessed with losing
I love losing I love losing because I
know exactly what you're thinking about
my loss and I can't wait to stick it in
your face when I come back
be more efficient with what you do to
allow you to do more things then you
don't have to worry about the subjective
and non controllable like knowing what's
good or great
that's the recap
[Music]